honestly the only reason I'm doing this
is because nobody ever takes me in these
survey things and I feel left out so
there's the truth I didn't do this last
year so today I'm going to answer all of
the questions from both of the surveys
from last year and this year in no
particular order let's go my full name
is charles joseph mcdonald mcdonald
meaning son of Donal which i've never
really understood although we do have a
family crest so that's quite cool joseph
was my paternal granddaughter named and
Charles came because my parents liked it
although I didn't clearly hence Charlie
my username came about because I
originally wanted charlie is cool but
that was taken so I added some more
words and that's the whole story
hmm so this coat is my most expensive
item of clothing 50 pounds of top man I
am NOT an adventurous clothes buyer
sorry I do however sometimes spend
embarrassingly large amounts of money on
other things for example my chair cost
me over 700 pounds which is more money
than some people spend on their first
car and my chair doesn't have an engine
now there's no correct time to have your
first kiss as one of the later bloomers
in the area of lady intimacy I was
pretty obsessed with the fact that I
just had to have my kiss because I felt
like I deserved it I was a very shy kid
so it did take me a while but when it
finally did happen it was slimy and not
particularly enjoyable but I was still
incredibly proud of myself the first gig
I ever went to was the magic numbers in
Bristol somewhere which was nice but not
a particularly interesting story however
the first gig that I ever played was
when I was in my first band we were
called half wink know we didn't realize
how stupid the name was we played two
songs and our schools Christmas Fair I
wrote both of them and have no memory of
either
and although the attentive audience
consisted exclusively of our parents I
still remember it being quite fun now
although I don't have any memory of
wanting a job when I was little I do
have this one distinct memory of me in
my first year of school sitting in front
of a computer and deciding that I
Charlie McDonnell lil Charlie wanted to
be a stay-at-home dad
with brown curly hair and a beard
needless to say that is still my
ultimate life goal in day to day life
the strangest thing I probably eaten is
pheasant which boringly is sort of just
like fancy chicken although when I had
mine it came with bullets still in the
bird and I didn't know that at the time
so I could have killed myself choking
yeah I did want to drink a milkshake
containing ketchup and fish fingers
among other things though so apparently
my dietary choices can be pretty out
there
so long as it's for the purposes of the
internet now personally I appreciate the
fact that my name is relatively simple
common and uncomplicated because it just
made my life nice and easy so naturally
when I have children I'm going to name
all eight of them Charlie no surname
you've just Charlie no in terms of
specific names that's up to me and the
person that I decide to have the babies
with if I even decide to have babies
which I don't know yet although I don't
have a favorite schoolteacher my
favorite teacher generally is mrs.
McEwan who used to give me speech and
drama lessons after school every single
week I was such a shy kid when I was
younger and so I don't think that I
would have started YouTube if it hadn't
been for mrs. McEwan giving me the
confidence to put myself out there into
the world so thanks Vivian that was good
I never had a group of school friends
there is no fun way to say that sentence
now I don't think anybody hated me in
fact I could get on pretty well with
just about anybody in school but I just
never found my place was only after I
left school and discovered YouTube that
my choice of potential friends widened
exponentially and I found people that I
really connected with so thank you the
Internet my favorite place in the world
is right here in my office in my house
in London it's not particularly exciting
or thrilling or anything like that it's
just comfortable and it's where my
friends are or if they're not here right
now it's where they can always come and
ultimately that's just what means more
to me not the places in my life but the
people already gonna take one person
kyrat O'Brien 89 because you can't have
over a thousand subscribers and not have
even one video on your channel it's just
rude
all right bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
here's something I probably should have
told you about ages ago whoa quality
t-shirts imagine the size of the stamp
that was required to create that piece I
need to get over my discomfort of
selling things to you which is probably
a good thing but I wouldn't have made
this if people hadn't asked me to make
it so if you want it here it is and if
you don't want it I'd be like that
[Music]